well you're looking at a booking photo
here of a former energy Department
official facing a felony charge good
evening to you thanks for joining us at
five I'm Brian Loftus I'm Kirsten Joyce
it's a story the eight news now
investigators first broke Sam brinton's
defense attorneys and prosecutors agreed
on a fifteen thousand dollar bail
Brinton is already out of jail Vanessa
Murphy has more on what unfolded moments
before Britain surrendered to police
this morning
no comment from Sam Britton as they
walked from Court here to turn
themselves in at jail do you care to
make a comment did you do this though
did you steal the luggage we have no
comment at this time there was an active
warrant for Britain for more than five
days after Metro Police say Britain was
caught on camera stealing luggage for a
second time before we'll go along with
the agreement and set bail on the amount
of fifteen thousand Britain was a deputy
assistant secretary at the department of
energy earlier this week the department
confirmed they're no longer an employee
there though Britain considered
non-binary so using the pronouns they
and them Metro Police say Britain stole
luggage from Harry Reid International
Airport valued at about 3 700 in July
the case was at a standstill until
police say they saw news stories about a
similar allegation in Minneapolis that
case is also ongoing it was a mention of
another case out of state so obviously
it's in your interest to stay out of
trouble again we tried getting Britain's
side of the story would you do an
interview with us down the line
absolutely not not at least why not to
give us your side of the story I don't
have a side of the story Britain is
expected back in court here in January
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now